here with reaction former senior
counselor to president trump kellyanne
conway also former white house chief of
staff mark meadows former white house
chief of staff also uh reince priebus
will toss a coin who is the better chief
of staff we'll let kellyanne make the
final toss
um
kellyanne we'll start with you tonight
because
president trump was right again you know
it's when people said well donald trump
fought with the press he called them
fake news media and and etc etc um the
country was so much better off i never
thought it would get this bad this fast
and i don't think any american did
no they did not unless time that it
takes to have a baby shawn they
basically unraveled these great
accomplishments and started to ruin
america look when the white house in
which the three of us worked nobody ever
wondered who is the president who's in
charge and what is he thinking
all of those were assured at every
moment but i have to say something about
the montage of lunacy you treated us to
at the beginning of your monologue
it should not be an occupational hazard
to work at the united states supreme
court as a justice or to be a family
member of one of those justices some of
them have small children i think many of
them have spouses and the threats that
are going to their safety to their lives
are very worrisome it is american to
disagree to dissent to protest
it is a crime to threaten people's lives
and worse and publish their addresses
and and try to incite the kind of
violence that we've seen in the past
and uh they're saying ruth sent us
referring to the late
justice ruth bader ginsburg no she
didn't she wasn't for violence like that
she never compelled anybody never
incited people to go to folks houses
she and the great antonin scalia were
the best of friends by all accounts so i
really hope everybody turns down the
temperature and law enforcement gets
involved because i'm very concerned but
as for these accomplishments look
everybody knows putin
kim jong-un
iran
xi jinping they were all at bay when
donald trump was in there gas prices
were lower but our morale was higher too
you know in the polls that actually
include issue sets but also ask just
about the state of the nation people are
very unhopeful i think the last time
people really had hope was in on
election day 2016 when they felt there
was going to be somebody different doing
something differently and now they're
just unraveling spite is no way to run a
country joe biden thinks donald trump
did it i undo it spite is no way to run
a country folks and that's what we've
got
so the maga movement according to joe
biden
mark meadows
the maga movement is the single greatest
danger uh
and big most radical group in america uh
let's see people that believe in energy
independence secure borders
constitutionals on the bench free and
fair trade peace through strength that's
so radical it's so over the top i've
never heard such ideas that were that
crazy
well listen sean uh kellyanne is exactly
right when we were in the white house
you didn't have to guess who was the
president of the united states because
president donald j trump was calling the
shots and actually using the maga
movement which is more than just the
republican party that's where joe biden
got it wrong we've got democrats and
unaffiliated
voters that are part of the maga
movement that says that they believe
that america should be great we should
celebrate the the greatness and when joe
biden actually leaves 85 billion dollars
worth of weapons to the taliban that
should be condemned and when they start
to politicize the supreme court as
they've done with leaking this document
and ultimately by calls to pack the
court and expand the number of justices
so that liberal progressives can get
their way it's just not what america is
all about but it is what politics is all
about and that's why we should be
calling out many of the progressive left
that have an attack on the supreme court
you know reince i brought up the 570
riots in the summer of 2020. we had
dozens of dead americans um we had
thousands of cops injured we had
billions of property damage uh i played
the rhetoric kellyanne referred to it
and
and the democratic party as a whole
their silence was deafening almost the
entire time
it seems to me that when it comes to
criticizing their radical base and then
i played comments of prominent democrats
and the ones who want to punch
donald trump in the pace face and dream
an awful lot about blowing up the white
house
nothing ever happens to them but if it
was a conservative if one day sean
hannity lost his mind and said something
that stupid
i don't think i'd ever do another show
ever for the rest of my life and i might
have the fbi at my door asking a lot of
questions and they might put me in these
really nice looking handcuffs that they
have
well that is so true and and here where
here's where we're at these are the
tactics of liberals in america the good
news is
is that i think
americans are starting to reject these
tactics and what are the tactics uh one
is false labeling they want to call
everyone a white supremacist has a maga
hat on who doesn't think that crt should
be taught in school they call parent
science deniers because they don't want
their two-year-olds and their
five-year-olds wearing masks they call
people who don't think that boys should
compete against girls in sports
transphobics
then they move to d platforming and they
say that if you post anything that we
don't agree with you're up on twitter
you're off of facebook you're up to
instagram now elon musk says you know
basically go jump in a lake i'm gonna
take care of twitter then what do they
do then they resort to violence and it's
blm and it's antifa and these are the
reason why to answer your question is
that these are the tactics embraced by
liberals and every once in a while i
look at the rules for radicals and we've
talked about this before but one of them
in in this rules for radicals is to find
ways to intimidate marginalize
and and and isolate and punish
individuals
that espouse opinions that you don't
agree with sean it's embedded in what
they believe and how they operate so
this is not a surprise but i do think
americans are starting to have enough of
this stuff and uh that's why they're
going to get killed in november
kellyanne when i played chuck schumer
threatening gorsuch and kavanagh was
that a threat because i think it was
yes it was and as for chuck schumer i
want this old white guy telling me what
to do with my body sean and how to think
uh that's very woke of you go ahead no
it was a threat it was a threat he went
to their place at work and threatened
them
right by the way have you noticed
there's always cameras involved they
have to bother ted and heidi cruz at
dinner kiersha nielsen the secretary of
homeland they've always got their camera
out and then they go which makes you
wonder but i think it's all escalated
now and it's because of something you
said earlier which is that people are
lying about what would happen if in fact
that opinion holds and roe versus weed
and no longer exist um of course
abortion will be accessible people are
lying about that and the left benefits
from the fact that a majority of
americans when you ask them what did roe
versus wade actually provide they get it
wrong the democrats love that people
know planned parenthood gets a half a
billion dollars in taxpayer money they
were caught selling fetal tissue and
baby body parts a few years ago they're
for ninth month abortion they're for sex
election abortion they're for
taxpayer-funded abortion i would ask
every liberal out there every
pro-choicer just can you think of one
abortion you think is a bad idea just
one tell us describe it we have many
states that are allowed for that
kellyanne we put up on the the states in
this union that allow abortion up until
the moment of birth and then of course
we played ralph northrup let me let me
ask
yeah let me ask mark this question now
that they're giving out the addresses of
supreme court justices clearly this is
all an effort to intimidate them mark
and and maybe make the case as
as people like the congenital liar adam
schiff and elizabeth warren are
suggesting we pack the courts um
but
my message to conservatives
are would be
never give out
the address of any justice any elected
official anybody that works on the
lowest level of government uh and if you
ever see anybody in public leave them
the hell alone say hello if you want be
nice otherwise leave them alone
well
leave them alone and certainly what
they're calling uh on a lot of the the
left to do uh and going to protest at at
some of these justices homes uh is is
not only inappropriate but it's
dangerous listen we're all we love this
country and being able to protest and
exp express your opinion is something
that we should be able to peacefully do
and you can do those uh you know in in
the public square but to suggest that
doxing you know someone and giving out
their address
this is all about intimidation this is
what the left
has mastered and they continue to master
it and where are the democrats
condemning this you know when when you
think of the supreme court
no matter what the makeup of the court
has been is or will be uh you you want
them to be a neutral arbiter of of the
truth and yet what we see are
politicians and the left uh particularly
uh pushing their agenda uh in in this
leaked document uh is is really an
affront on the supreme court in that
neutrality
let me give you the last word same
question i i really now fear
for these justices um and i would never
want a conservative to ever act in the
same way reince priebus
no never and and and and i think that's
the difference between republicans
democrats liberals and conservatives
uh live by the golden rule do unto
others as you want to be done to
yourself but the real question the real
issue here is that democrats and
liberals as kellyanne said they've taken
it too far they went to late term
abortion they went to
taxpayer abortions and then they said
we're not gonna tell parents when a 15
year old girl wants to go after school
and have an abortion and that's when
parents rose up and parents are rising
up all over this country like they did
in virginia they're doing it here and
they're doing it across red states in
america and they're calling the question
to the courts and and the justices are
are likely to respond
all right thank you all for being with
us we appreciate it hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else